[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Ey
ve
sant boi'de yaşamak
Yaşıyor
ele geçirmek
cantv
bu yanıkları göndererek
ve masa
Evet
şehir şarkı söylüyor
[Müzik]
altmıştan fazla ve daha fazla anahtar görmek
gelir
amaya
[Müzik]
Ey
bak sanz
top
D
fince palmata
benim yolum
en az
olgun
başka bir konu sayıyor
[Müzik]
hissedene kadar
sahip olmak
öldürürken
[Müzik]
Böyle
hafta
[Müzik]
marsa
Bence
[Müzik]
Ey
[Alkış]
ile
ve youtube'dan hiçbir şey lario'ya dokunmadı
eibar'ın bildiği oto dansları yap
İslamcılar beni elport ederken fark ettiler
dedi dvorak web sipariş listesi
yarım konuşmak zorundayız
bana açıklamanın ademi merkeziyetçiliği
sivil istasyonlar tanrıyı sevdiğini hayal et
Hayır
Ey
[Müzik]
perez ile ölçüldüğü nerede yazıyor bu nedenle
ve hiçbir şey
savunucularını benim olduğun yerde hayal et
finaldeyim
bir kraliçe yüzer
[Müzik]
Ey
peki o zaman tekrar
[Müzik]
benim için
Evet
[Müzik]
bakmak
kraliçe o kadar
[Müzik]
artı
Ey
guasave'de değerler uygulandı
[Müzik]
ve başka bir şey yok
ama başka hiç bir şey
hiçbir geliri veya hiçbir şeyi olmayan insanlar
[Müzik]
ve hiçbir şey
bir kız
[Müzik]
Ey